November of
2014 it is the age of the mascot if
Super Smash Brothers for Wii U is to be
believed another smash another fluid and
fantastic fighting game in a beloved
series that captures that undeniable
Nintendo magic for many this is the game
that personifies the age a return to the
pure unfettered joy of friendly
competition November of 2014 it is the
age of Pokémon presuming you got to
catch them all Omega Ruby and Alpha
Sapphire may be remakes but they are
remakes that capture the charm that
keeps millions of players returning to
the Pokémon Arena whether you're a new
trainer or an expert Handler the newest
pair of role playing games makes the
case that this is indeed the Pokémon
age November of 2014 it is the age of
the Blockbuster for anyone drawn to the
big budget bravado that commands your
attention and drains your wallet during
the holiday season Far Cry 4 Call of
Duty advanced warfare and Assassin's
Creed are all buying for your dollars
along with re-releases of Halo and Grand
Theft Auto games if you love slick
production values showstopping cutcenes
and adventures stuffed with activities
this is your
age where GameSpot is concerned however
November 2014 is the age of drag Dragons
Dragon Age Inquisition hasn't captured
our imaginations because of the way it
aders to bioware's proven role-playing
formula but because of the way it
deviates intriguing characters and
game-changing choices may lead you
through inquisition's main plot but the
story that really counts is the one you
create for yourself as you explore the
game's expansive regions every dungeon
Harbors secrets and every sight draws
you in for a closer look and then
there's that moment when when you see a
dragon descend from the heavens for the
first time it's a huge and marvelous
creature but facing it with your level
five party would prove disastrous in
time however you will face and Vanquish
that Dragon you might also romance your
favorite companion uncover the truth
about red lium and find out more about
Bianca var's beloved crossbow you hobnob
with the political elate enhance your
armor with dragon scales and direct an
entire institution that determines who
lives are worthy enough to preserve and
whose deserve to be snuffed out that
Dragon Age Inquisition connects you with
its characters and World Isn't So
surprising that the game's immense
spaces don't diminish these connections
is its true Triumph yes indeed it is the
age of dragons and thus it is fitting
that Dragon Age Inquisition be awarded
game swats game of the month for
November